Kyle Rittenhouse was found not guilty of
criminal charges for killing multiple
people at his criminal trial but is now
being sued by the family of one of the
men he shot dead in 2020. and by Gage
gross kreutz as well whom he injured
Kyle Rittenhouse is begging just begging
people on Tucker Carlson's show send me
money because it's so unfair what
they're doing to me uh the funniest part
and and this really is funny
when the time comes for ritten house to
give the URL where you can donate to him
he mangles the URL this is the whole
reason he was on the show this that
check this out no idea oh and just to be
let me explain one other thing
he's being sued civilly remember you can
be found criminally Not Guilty by the
standard of Reasonable Doubt
and then
responsible civilly for the same death
of an individual that you caused so just
remember that that he's being sued
civilly now no idea it's it's ridiculous
it's lawsuit it's very frustrating and
It's upsetting this is frustrating to me
an attack on our Second Amendment rights
and our rights to self-defense right and
it's saying if you use your god-given
right to self-defense they're going to
come after you if you win a court you're
acquitted rightfully so
they're going to take you to civil court
and they're going to file they're going
to take you for everything you're worth
they're going to drive you into
bankruptcy and drown you in a mountain
of legal bills and I know we're going to
win to court but it's going to be
expensive it's going to cost a lot of
money to fight these attorneys they're
very powerful you can go to
www.givesango.com
okay
www.givesonggo.com I have no clue what
the hell that is our slash cloud rented
house to help me let's hear it once more
attorneys are very powerful you can go
to
www.givesango.com
rented house give Sango to help me take
on these lawyers so they don't come
after more people because if they can
come after me they will come after you
right will they though I'm not sure
about that why would they come up why
would they come after people who haven't
done what Kyle Rittenhouse chose to do
so here's the deal with this he wants
you to think that if he's been acquitted
criminally it's unfair that you should
be able to be sued civilly but that's
just how the system works you know these
these people talk about respect for Law
and Order and all of it this is the way
it works criminal law deals with crimes
considered harmful to society as a whole
murder theft assault Etc criminal law
would punish offenders deter others from
committing similar crimes in some
theoretical sense rehabilitate okay it
doesn't happen too often criminal cases
are initiated by the government the
burden of proof is on the prosecution to
prove the defendant's guilt Beyond a
reasonable doubt if you're found guilty
you might have fines imprisonment or
other forms of punishment the modern
legal system we have is based on common
law developed in England adopted in many
countries like the United States and it
also includes civil law this is a
Bedrock Foundation of our legal system
he might not like it but it is and when
there are disputes between individuals
could be a contractual dispute could be
a personal injury claim which is what
we're talking about here the purpose of
civil law
is cases brought by a plaintiff to
compensate an injured party for the
suffer the harm that they suffered and
civil cases are initiated by the injured
party not the government it's a
different burden which is a
preponderance of evidence sort of like
thinking about
51 likely or that's not actually the way
lawyers would describe it but it is a
different standard and you can be found
not guilty criminally and responsible
civilly if you support law and order if
you claim as Kyle Rittenhouse does to
support all of these different aspects
of of our system this is part of the
system and you can't pick and choose
which is all they want to do he doesn't
like it he also doesn't understand it
similar when Trump said how can they
impeach me again they already impeached
me well it's for something different or
how can they impeach me when Mueller
cleared me well Mueller didn't clear you
of obstruction but it has nothing to do
the Mueller probe has nothing to do with
whether you can be impeached they would
like things to work differently than
they do but this is it pathetic Kyle
Rittenhouse now begging for money and
you can go to a URL I couldn't even
understand I guess uh if you want to
donate I've had such trouble finding a
great razor where I am not cutting
myself or getting those Nicks on my skin
which are so common with the cheap
disposable razors you have to meet our
sponsor Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below